c'est en plein coeur de la beauce que
sont nées des célèbres petits gâteaux
vachon
mais il existe désormais un autre gâteau
qui fait la renommée de cette région
le beauceron à l'érable petit arrêt à la
cabane à sucre pour le découvrir
c'est enfin le moment où on peut enfin
goûter
c'est très très léger c'est très soyeux
aussi soyons pas de crème le pour
beaucoup voici le créateur de ce gâteau
michel beaudoin mais j'en utilise
beaucoup le moi je le suis aussi qu'un
fai présentation du gros saule zighout
le ciel à première vue ce gâteau
ressemble à bien d'autres vendus en
épicerie mais avec le sirop d'érable
comme premier ingrédient il se démarque
rapidement dans l'est présentement au
bar mi-temps à tring jonction
tout a débuté ici c'était en 2006 michel
alors propriétaire est cuisinier dans ce
restaurant depuis de nombreuses années
ressentais le besoin d'un nouveau défi
professionnel une bonne journée est
arrivé que juste à cuisiner ou marmitons
je faisais ma blonde j'ai dit je pense
qu'on va laisser la restauration puis je
devais faire mon rêve depuis longtemps
que je rêve j'ai dit je vous refais
ringot trop d'erreurs puis je vois le
vendent partout en province
moi je veux 25 cents à grande gueule au
hockey par semaine pour personne aux
deux ça va être notre athlète il a
littéralement mis la main à la pâte à la
recherche de la bonne recette
j'ai travaillé je vous dirai au moins
une vingtaine d'heures par semaine ça
allait durer pendant quatre ans alors il
ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de deux soirs et
de st roch qui avant que ce soit en
entreprise en phase iib combier
manuellement comme ce juste boulot on a
commencé avec six par semaine
maintenant on est monté à 24 par semaine
puis aujourd'hui vous en faites conviés
par semaine en moyenne 2500 à 3000
gâteau semaine bienvenue à l' usine de
fabrication des gâteaux de michel
voyez vous un grec de cet ordre là il ya
120 ans autour de 900 grammes on les
fabrique à trois personnes en plus des
boues seront à l'érable on cuisine ici
une autre création de michel le choc aux
érables fait que c'est une méthode comme
nos mères nos gamins faisait hockey la
seule chose que moi j'ai fait je livre
est fini
moi je viens d'une famille qui était pas
au hockey alors quand j'ai fait de bons
sons et ram ma première chose que j'ai
dit moi je veux créer un produit qui est
bon qui est plus 5 pour la santé parce
qu'avec des produits qui sont sans la
conservation sans produits chimiques ou
quoi que ce soit et je suis très sérieux
comme ici avec clientèle soyez
raisonnable parce que la santé c'est
d'être raisonnable que des produits
naturels peu d'être mais comme tout
gâteaux sucrés très caloriques mon
cerveau il vient mon fournisseur il
demeure à brothers
moi je ne suis pas un choriste a dû tout
quitter un hashtag autorisé par la
fédération
moi j'achète sirop de mes producteurs et
sam beaugey quarantaine de producteurs
qui me fournisse le sirop qu'est ce qui
est particulièrement important info dire
composé le tiers du sirop au québec donc
emporté on a plus de chances d'offrir le
meilleur 6 0 parce qu'elle est que les
conditions sont gagnants peu mou de la
beauce notre durée de production est une
des plus longues au québec on compte
plus de 16 millions dans taille en
beauce répartis entre trois mille deux
cents producteurs pour michel c'est pour
ces gros râteau pour voir la couleur
faut descendre au niveau du cerveau plus
font mousser en descendant au niveau de
la couleur de plus foncé on a un groupe
les plus goûteuses l'épicerie iga de
sainte marie de beauce est le plus gros
vendeur si on était vraiment le premier
à l'intégrer dans les magasins géo puis
à l'offrir au public on a fait de
grandes dégustations
puis les gens commencent à y connecte
manson et contrôlable c'est michel
voulait aborder la retraite en vendant
150 gâteau par semaine on peut dire
qu'il a raté sa cible
ces convois de plus gras fierté
aujourd'hui c'est un bon sens
[Musique]